i'd like to introduce you to someone
his name is simon and i hate him hello
simon
this is balthazar he's an evil demon who
spits fire in my throat goiters huh
anyway i've been looking over these
photographs of the restaurant and i've
identified several other known mob types
ah what is it did you see something no i
just got very cold very fast
and now my entire body is somehow on
fire oh
these mumps are jerks whoo i also
noticed
this van is parked out front in several
other photographs i never noticed that
the restaurant must have been under
surveillance i bet it was the feds
they're right i'll reach out to my
contact at the bureau see if i can get
us some footage
good idea also i know you're not
supposed to but i kind of want to poke
my mump
bad idea i'm going in here we go oh
it hurt how did i not see that coming
i feel dizzy this might just be the
fever talking but this unedited footage
of an italian restaurant from eight
years ago might be the best movie i've
ever seen
also how weird are forks forks are very
weird i've
always thought so yeah yeah
did we take too much cold medicine not
by a long shot balthazar is a thirsty
[__]
huh i'll drink to that
[Music]
wait look
gargamargo oh sorry
can't talk need more medicine
garibaldi he's eating snakes
no it's spaghetti uh it's
always spaghetti i'm just saying if
that's spaghetti
it looks like snakes wait a minute
why did you just go in the kitchen do we
have eyes in the kitchen your eyes
everywhere man
ow ow icky icky out look
he slipped the chef a piece of paper i
bet it's the address of his hideout the
chef knows where the hideout is
his name is richie lignardi we talk to
him
we find garibaldi we have to go right
now
go where haha what's on your face huh oh
right uh yes my disgusting deformity um
here let me just hey what's up girl
better it's not worse we're on our way
right now to talk to a lead that knows
where garibaldi's hideout is
you're quarantined you can't go outside
spewing mumps like a couple of mumph
fountains
not like this we can't
[Music]
stop you can't leave at all good luck
trying to stop us
you'll never catch us
amy is usain bolt is this the piece of
paper you're looking for
you found the address no it's a recipe
for baked ziti
it was taped to your wall the entire
time you're delirious and you're sick
and you definitely didn't solve the case
you need to go back inside
well i can't my leg stopped working
oh my testicles the bumps have reached
my testicles
all right just finish taking off your
totally ineffective biohazard suits and
have a little rest
nonsense santiago we just have to buckle
down and work harder we simply hit a
bump in the road
more like a mump in the road
[Laughter]
such a good one jay can i talk to you in
private for a minute sure thing
let me just snag this cover up the old
swell sack
all right okay so here's the deal i have
a high fever and i can't control my body
but you can do whatever you want to me
oh but don't touch my mouth neck or
testicles
you've badly misread the situation oh
thank god
jake you need to drop this case what are
you talking about the plan is working
perfectly hold hasn't been lonely all
week yeah because he's too busy almost
dying look at him
what he's just beautiful minding it
because he's a genius
he's writing the word case over and over
again
oh now he's spelling it with a k is that
not how you spell it again i have a
mouth neck and testicle melting fever
jake enough is enough you need to drop
this stupid back burner cold case before
you both die
or i will kill you
oh my god i thought i was following her
yeah i should probably lie down
here we go caves
you